alors qu'en 6 salaire pour toi est ce
que c'est parce que ton père était
grutier sur le port d'alger que lorsque
le président mitterrand tu confies les
tribunes de la concorde pour le 14
juillet puis suspend les tôles et les
toitures adea des grandes rues comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
j'ai passé mon enfance sur le port
d'alger avec mon père qui était grutiers
et donc j'ai eu l'occasion de monter
dans la tête de flèche et de las de voir
des paysages extraordinaires notamment
méditerranée et la ville d'alger jackass
pas d'autre et c'est vrai que quand vous
puisqu'il s'agissait donc encore
architecture quand je me dise de la
culture nous proposer participer à ce
concours
la première idée que j'avais j'ai eu
quoi à ce moment là c'était deux essayé
de me suspendre un taux métallique
manière très aériennes et pour ça il
fallait trouver des supports c'est bien
et la culture c'est pas dangereux
non c'est pas dangereux s'ils
s'attendent maginot quand même oui c'est
c'est ce qui a été dit à une époque il
n'y avait aucun risque que les services
de sécurité plus de sécurité technique
est là pour prouver que le projet tenait
au dessus de la tête du président et du
gouvernement
loin de ces hommes de marc conrad risque
de décapiter la france n'a pas plus que
ça te fait un centre procédé rsa
marne-la-vallée six boîtes ce que tu as
fait là bas c'était un centre pour la
recherche de l'image informatique et la
communication en inde aller et avec ce
projet j'ai obtenu en 1988 du premier
prix d'architecturé public
ça fait deux matches aux as fait un
immeuble de bureaux une mode a fait
l'école qu'est fameuse rue pelleport
quelle est la constante de toutes les
travaux quand on dit que du conjugue
l'art conceptuel avec les hautes
technologies le vert et cetera c'est un
peu une façon de résumer tu penses
oui c'est une façon de me résumer je
suis très intéressé par la l'art
conceptuel et on peut citer enfin j'ai
quelques artistes comme notamment
cristaux qui tient qu'au moins un des
leaders de la france et artistiques
actuelles c'est-à-dire essayer de de
poursuivre dans des demandes et des
grandes mains dans les grands gestes de
paysages des idées qui sont très simples
et qui tient uniquement par la valeur de
l'idée et non pas parce qu'on y met
autour
la technologie est et dans
l'architecturé forcément un événement
de base la construction et doit être au
service d'un concept et d'une idée s'il
n'y a pas de concept au départ il peut
pas y avoir d'entité cure orthez le
grand prix d'architecturé cette année
grand prix national d'architecturé 40
berges pas mal c'est bien je suis
effectivement en plus jeunes à venir
doit pas être plus contemporaine cette
année après 7,1 christian de portzamparc
ils veulent avoir normalement non plus
sa cécité à sa fin et les tickets c'est
vrai que je n'enlève rien au talent de
christian de portzamparc ou le jury en a
décidé autrement
ouais un jury autonome international 1
qui après lui et raymond inverse à celui
de christian de portzamparc sait
toutefois qu'il est pas un jeu comme
plane parce que ce n'est pas une
justification à priori puisque tu été
choisie comme lauréat du concours du
dernier des grands chantiers du
président mitterrand finalement est-ce
que c'était pas une façon à priori tu
donner un peu de bouteille de cela
quelques mois avant je pressens les
jurys étaient totalement indépendants
les uns des autres
il ya eu deux contexte complètement
différent qui n'ont aucun rapport les
uns avec les autres et je crois que le
travail
que j'ai fait j'ai monté depuis une
dizaine d'années avec une récompense et
il est reconnu que c'est toi qui bien
qu'ils semblaient alors le centre
international de conférences aujourd'hui
il est avenue kléber c'est là où qui
s'ignorent discuter avec le duc tho et
puis maintenant on va le mettre quai
branly donc et tu appris cette nouvelle
c'est toi qui choisis tu as appris cette
nouvelle le jour de pâques 41 ans
la fête continue alors tu a imaginé un
projet on en parlait ces trois boîtes en
verre juxtaposés alors parlez nous de la
boîte est bon le projet se compose en
gros de trois coffrets de fer qui
contiennent tout simplement chacun un
des éléments du programme dans l'un il
ya une grande végétation une grande
partie réservé à la visitation des
journalistes
ces communes c'est là où il ya des
arbres intérieur il ya surtout ces
expressions notion d'une place publique
avec j'espère que vous lisez en faire
gagner ce sera pas seulement sur le
projet d'ici seront vraiment et j'espère
qu'ils y seront 29 mai
n'y at il pas une analogie entre les
oiseaux les journalistes journalistes
alors que ça très beau je trouve que
c'est très positif ayant peut-être
reprocher d'avoir comparé des
journalistes à des réseaux moi je trouve
cette première maison la plume en commun
peut absolument
bon déjà c'est ellen pas tous la même
chose maison la plus chère la vision qui
se sert de la pub ça ne gagnaient
ressasser la première boîte disons c'est
celle qui étalait cela ccsl donc pour
les journalistes les arbres les oiseaux
a promis il ya un hall d'accueil immense
hall d'accueil navette sous plafond
puisque osman est temps de mettre toute
la france
100 m de long 30 50 mètres de large un
des plus grands halls d'accueil du monde
qui sera à l'image de la france et les
représentants qui peut la solidité de la
diplomatie place et y développe ses
blancs c'est même de l'univers de la
communication de la deûle échange de
l'espace uniquement c'est comme si on
avait mis une partie de paris comme
avait pris l'économie ouverte sans avoir
cherché à les essayer de la contenir
tu as juste un bout de paris et la
troisième contient des diplomates
le diplomate parlait des auditoriums des
salles de réunion mais là c'est noir la
saison voit pas c'est un espace jeudi
plutôt noir c'est quelque chose qui est
ressemble un petit peu golconde
tableau de magritte seo passivité au
poteau prévenir des regards des tirs
éventuels de terroriser de sécurité
terrorisme prise d'otages tout ce dont
on est en droit ce niveau de la sécurité
diplomate
mais c'est surtout un espace très dense
où il se passe plein de choses des
conférences internationales les salaires
des salle de 700 places en grand
auditorium qui contient 1500 places de
1000 places je dirais c'est là qu'est le
lieu véritable de la diplomatie lors ce
projet du mois est-ce que c'est passé
très style mitterrand sûr c'est un peu
comme la pyramide c'est un peu comme
l'arche de la défense
est ce que t'as pas fait pour plaire est
ce que tu t'es pas dit comme ces
vétérans qui va choisir après tout
faisons du bon style mitterrand comme ça
il va être d'accord donc dans une tente
est ce que c'est que ce public avant
même que le ch'ti mitterrand c'est là
qu'il delà de la modernité c'est ce
qu'ils payent a été grande bibliothèque
est comme ça aussi leur le projet de
perrault est un peu comme ça pourquoi
g20 contient effectivement quatre tours
rr n'estime pas aujourd'hui de matériaux
il remplacera pierre pas fait pour
plaire non pas je fais ce que j'ai envie
de faire comme toujours ça serait quand
même des projets a toujours été fait en
fonction de ce que je pensais de nos
concepts de minéraux pas français mais
ça sera prudent 94 pour la france va
présider la commission européenne la
france prend le président de la
commission de la communauté européenne
en janvier 95 game maker gens vivaient
d'eric alors ouais non ça se voit quand
même livré à l'édifice en septembre 1994
et ça sera fait ça sera fait tous les
mois du tangage et c'est bon nous avons
des planning est respecté nous le
respecterons pour le moment c'est très
beau ton truc la santé xi classe c'est
beau c'est possible de se construire ça
va tenir son avenir oui la symbologie
actuelle permet de faire au moins tenir
le bâtiment assure étonnamment bon
maintenant mais pour l'entretenir ce
truc parce que quand tu as beau bourg sa
route dans tous les sens quand même
comment vous allez faire
il ya un mec avec de l'adjectif qui fait
se paie tout le comment ça va faire ça
sera robotisée mais on a tiré la leçon
de neubourg justement tu travailles
résidence un truc comme ça toi sans
problème un monde merveilleux je
préférerais pas diplomate bel immeuble
haussmannien des familles non je pense
que c'est un bâtiment qui traduit la
modernité et la volonté dans la vente il
était le maître du monde
m en belgique c'est le maître du monde
la mer sera belle
les miliciens pour moi tout cas ce que
patrice evra se mettre que je gagne
ridgway situe qu'à serait quoi à paris
tout viendrait juste massacré quand on
rêve en architecture c'est quoi mon rêve
oui ce que tu as dit une fois je veux
faire quelque chose qui soit à la
hauteur de ce que les beatles ont fait
avec les sons dans l'imaginons qu il
puisse réaliser ton rêve architectural
tout bois non quoi j'ai parlé des
beatles c'était pour moi le
la référence delà de la musique
contemporaine c'est à dire qu'ils en
rêvaient ils ont réussi ça c'est quand
même assez fantastique à faire de la
musique contemporaine que personne ni de
coke musique en même temps intéressé
toutes les couches sociales toutes les
catégories les grands les petits des
moyens à jeudi et ça c'est devenu
populaire est arrivé à faire la fois
quelque chose de très conceptuelle
intellectuelle et en même temps
populaire c'est vrai est-ce qu'on
peuvent atteindre le même niveau
graphique et pour moi je pense que cette
possibilité je serai qui s'ils n'étaient
pas francis soler
ce serait qui voilà ça c est compliqué
j'aimerais bien un john lennon a pas
morts vivants et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus